North Korea says the Trump
administration's decision to label at a
state sponsor of terrorism is a serious
provocation a government statement
released by North Korean state media
called the designation a quote violent
infringement upon our dignified country
Kim jong-un's regime has not said
anything about the dramatic escape of
one of its soldiers who ran across the
border into South Korea Ben Tracy is in
Beijing with new details on the defector
and what his condition might say about
life in North Korea
Ben good morning good morning so most
North Korean defectors head north and
crossed the border with China trying to
escape across the heavily armed border
with South Korea is considered a suicide
mission
but somehow this soldier survived and
may now provide some valuable
information we don't yet know the
identity of the North Korean soldier who
daringly drove his army jeep to the
border and then ran for his life his
former comrades fired off about 40 shots
hitting him at least five times
South Korean trauma surgeon ekoo chu
operated on the soldier and says he
found dozens of parasitic worms in his
digestive tract as well as uncooked corn
signs of malnutrition the soldier is 24
years old but at just five feet five and
weighing 132 pounds he is significantly
smaller than an average 18 year old in
South Korea doctors reportedly say he
has tuberculosis and hepatitis B last
April we visited North Korea as it
staged one of its elaborate military
parades many of the soldiers we saw
looked more like children likely the
result of a brutal famine in the north
in the 1990s South Korean intelligence
officials will now want to question the
defector about his escape hoping he may
provide a glimpse into Kim Jong Un's
reclusive regime and information about
whether recent UN sanctions are taking a
toll he would be questioned to see how
legitimately he might be a real defector
or is this actually not the case
Sukie kim worked undercover as a teacher
in north korea for six months and has
written extensively about defectors she
thinks this kind of escape is so rare
in over-the-top that it could be a set
up by North Korea to create an incident
with the south and the soldier is just
upon if North Korea and government
staged this dramatic Great Escape that
really reeks of a Hollywood firm which
in some way would not be that surprising
I think one thing I have learned by
following them with Korea for over a
decade and living there is that almost
everybody is a victims you know they are
deserving the great leader of the South
Korean media says that this soldier who
crossed the border is suffering from
depression and PTSD and that doctors had
to hang up a South Korean flag in his
hospital room just to assure him that he
actually did escape from North Korea
what Ben Tracy and Beijing thank you Ben